und ich begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich hier
im studio rainer wendt chef der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
schon gut ihnen ja wir haben jetzt
einige informationen zum gestrigen tag
erhaltene und ihre beamten die polizei
die bekommt die informationen alt dort
dann hinnehmen sie uns einmal mit wenn
man in so eine situation kommt man
bekommt nun die nachricht menschenmenge
autor eingereist was sind denn die
größten herausforderungen die größten
aufgaben die sich den beamten vor ort
als erstes stellen und zunächst einmal
das was die feuerwehren mit der polizei
gemeinsam macht nämlich sich um die
verletzten kümmern da gibt es ja schwer
und leicht verletzte menschen sind in
panik diesen aufgeregt und hier sich
möglichst rasch an den überblick zu
verschaffen um dann die einsatzmaßnahmen
einzuleiten und zu koordinieren
die da sind natürlich sich um die
verletzten zu kümmern aber auch des
fahrers habhaft zu werden dann den
tatort abzusperren und mit der
ermittlungsarbeit zu beginnen und das
ist ja eine langwierige
ermittlungsarbeit das heißt die
spurensicherung die muss hinterher auch
für das staatsanwaltschaftliche
ermittlungsverfahren möglicherweise für
einen gerichtsverfahren ganz akribisch
gemacht werden das konnte man gestern
auch beobachten es waren ja dafür diese
tatortarbeit günstige verhältnisse es
gab kein regen kein schnee keine
dunkelheit die spuren mussten also nicht
besonders geschützt werden sondern
mussten gekennzeichnet werden konnten
dann auch gesichert werden aber es
dauerte stunden
das ist eben bei einer so
professionellen arbeit der fall polizei
hat was die bewältigung solcher
einsatzlagen angeht eine menge
dazugelernt dazulernen müssen mit
traurigen erfahrungen die wir gemacht
haben aber auch mit heftigen vorwürfen
die der polizei hat immer wieder gemacht
wurden aber gäste man gestern konnte man
sehen dass die polizei als lernende
organisation funktioniert
sozusagen live konnte man sehen wie die
verschiedenen abschnitte gut miteinander
koordiniert wurden
ja die unmittelbar betroffenen
abzuschirmen und sie war von neugierigen
fragen in schutz zu nehmen herr vor
denjenigen die die unvermeidlichen
handy-nutzer die immer wieder filme
drehen und die menschen befragen das
natürlich eine wichtige herausforderung
in dem zusammenhang ist hat ja auch die
kirchen da einen sehr segensreichen
dienst geleistet dass sie das sofort
ihre türen weit geöffnet hat und gesagt
hat hierher das ist kirche das ist ein
schutzraum und das wurde vor ort sehr
gut organisiert aber ist für alle
beteiligten natürlich eine belastung
auch für die einsatzkräfte und man muss
schon sagen auch das ist auch in der
hauptstadt gut organisiert mittlerweile
dass die sozia psychologische betreuung
von opfern vernünftig funktioniert aber
auch die der antrifft und gleichzeitig
fragen weil es natürlich wie können wir
unsere innenstädte besser schützen das
ist ja eine frage die 2016 in ganz
großer dringlichkeit aufkam und dann
wurde eine quick identifikation gruppe
gegründet die war auch gestern wieder im
einsatz erklären sie uns einmal was für
eine sondereinheit das ist worauf man
sich da vorbereitet und vielleicht haben
sie auch vorschläge was brauchen sie was
braucht die polizei damit wir unsere
innenstädte unseren großen plätze unsere
fußgängerzonen unsere flaniermeilen
besser schützen kann doch zunächst
einmal die erkenntnis dass wir keinen
100 prozentigen schutz haben werden wir
haben hier wieder eine person von der
wir noch nicht genau wissen wie ist wie
psychologische die psychische situation
ist das ist jetzt teil der
ermittlungsarbeit wir haben eine
beschreibung dieser person da gibt es
hinweise auf psychische
beeinträchtigungen das ist noch keine
erklärung jetzt geht es darum die
hintergründe zu erfahren beispielsweise
auch die frage zu beantworten gab es
hinweise darauf dass sich diese person
möglicherweise zu einer gefährlichen tat
hinreißen lässt das haben wir in der
vergangenheit ja auch immer wieder
erlebt dass menschen schwer psychisch
gestört waren und dann aber auch schon
durch gewaltdelikte aufgefallen das ist
bislang nicht bekannt bisher gab es nur
eigentumsdelikte also diese erkenntnis
die muss erst noch reifen wir müssen
erst noch wissen was mit dem täter mit
dem beschuldigten tatsächlich los ist
die innenstädte beispielsweise der
breitscheidplatz den haben wir sofort in
der assoziation die räumliche nähe zu
diesem tatort auch das tatbegehungs
mittel nämlich fahrzeug gegen menschen
das weckt diese düstere assoziation
obwohl sicher zu sein scheint dass es
sich her nicht wie damals um einen
terroristischen anschlag handelt und
der breitscheidplatz ist ja im anschluss
daran gesichert worden da kommt kein lkw
und pkw mehr eingefahren
wenn man dorthin geht sieht man das
sieht ja auch ziemlich martialisch aus
diese sicherungsmaßnahmen
das hat sich mittlerweile an große
industrie entwickelt die also diese
zugangssperren für gefährdete bereiche
bei vielen fußgängerzonen sieht man das
aber man darf sich auch da nichts
vormachen wir können die innenstädte
nicht zu mauern das würde uns auch in
unserer bewegungsfreiheit und auch im
stadtbild zu sehr einschränken das heißt
ein bestimmtes restrisiko bleibt aber es
gibt durchaus noch mehr dinge die man
tun kann beispielsweise auch in der
hauptstadt nämlich das thema einsatz von
videotechnik im öffentlichen raum wieder
in den blick nehmen wir sind das einzige
land berlin ist das einzige land in ganz
deutschland in dem die polizei nicht aus
gefahrenabwehr gründen videotechnik über
öffentlichen raum einsetzen haben das
muss man sich wirklich mal vorstellen
andererseits hat berlin die größte
kamera dichte aber nur durch private
betreiber der polizei gab es nicht und
das ist schon ein umstand den man jetzt
in der diskussion vielleicht mal wieder
neu in den blick nehmen also es wird
gefilmt aber eben nicht aus überwachungs
gründen sondern aus privaten gründen sie
haben einen ganz wichtigen aspekt
angesprochen fahrzeuge gegen mensch
stände wieder ein auto das zu einer
tödlichen waffe wurde
ein auto als waffe
kaum ein angriff ist derart verheerend
und gleichzeitig so leicht zu begehen
wie mit dem transportmittel nummer eins
in deutschland erschreckend wie oft das
auch hierzulande schon passiert ist die
aktuellsten beispiele eine chronik des
pokers
[Musik]
volkmarsen februar 2020 am rosenmontag
steuert ein 29 jahre alter deutscher
sein auto absichtlich in die menge in
der nordhessischen stadt werden dutzende
menschen verletzt darunter 20 kinder
einen politischen hintergrund schließen
die ermittler aus wegen versuchten
mordes und gefährlicher körperverletzung
kommt der täter in untersuchungshaft
am 16 dezember 2021 wird der täter zu
einer lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt bottrop januar 2009 10 wenige
minuten nach dem jahreswechsel fährt ein
autofahrer im ruhrgebiet in eine
menschenmenge es gibt vier verletzte
zwei weitere versuche in bottrop und
essen passanten anzufahren schlagen fiel
der 50 jahre alte täter wird in die
geschlossene psychiatrie eingewiesen
münster april 2018 ein mann rast mit
einem campingbus in eine gruppe von
menschen vor einer beliebten gaststätte
dann erschießt er sich fünf menschen
sterben mehr als 20 werden verletzt die
ermittler gehen davon aus dass der täter
psychisch krank war heidelberg februar
2007 10 am rande der altstadt fährt ein
35 jähriger seinen mietwagen in eine
menschengruppe auf dem gehweg ein 73
jahre alter mann stirbt der täter gilt
als schuldunfähig die richter weisen in
dauerhaft in die psychiatrie
berlin juli 2006 während der fußball wm
fährt ein 33 jähriger mit seinem
kleinwagen absichtlich in die
menschenmenge auf der fanmeile am
brandenburger tor rund 20 menschen
werden verletzt der amokfahrer kommt in
eine psychiatrische klinik amok mit dem
auto einfach gas geben und wehrlose
menschen kein verbrechen ist so leicht
zu begehen und so schwer zu verhindern
rainer wendt chef der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft hier weiterhin bei
uns zu gast im studio das auto eine so
leichte und tödliche waffe aber auch das
etwas was man vermutlich nicht
verhindern kann nicht eindämmen kann
dass menschen immer wieder zu dieser
leichten und tödlichen waffe greifen ja
so ist es gibt ein grundrisiko das
bedeutet aber nicht dass man gar nichts
tun kann es gibt ja beispielsweise und
das haben wir ja auch in diesem beitrag
gesehen immer wieder menschen die
schwere psychische störungen haben die
auch vorher schon im visier von
gesundheitsbehörden beispielsweise sind
von denen eine gefahr ausgeht und
gelegentlich hat man den eindruck dass
nicht genügend getan wird um diese
menschen im blick zu behalten
sie werden dann später eine psychiatrie
eingewiesen und viele menschen fragen
sich zu recht muss erst immer etwas
schreckliches passieren bis der staat
auf sichtbare gefahren reagiert kann man
das nicht früher tun das ist im
einzelfall natürlich eine schwierige
entscheidung deshalb kann das auch nicht
irgendeine art tun muss braucht muss man
immer auch gerichte für haben und
behörden für haben wieder gut
ausgestattet sind aber genau das braucht
es auch und bei unseren
gesundheitsbehörden habe ich manchmal
zweifel ob die vernünftig ausgestattet
sind um solche gefährlichen menschen das
sind sie nochmals die sind
möglicherweise krank sind psychisch
gestört aber das bedeutet ja nicht dass
wir immer warten müssen sondern das
bedeutet dass man möglicherweise auch
früher maßnahmen ergreifen können ist
das passiert eine lehrerin ist tot der
mann ist in eine schülergruppe gerast
sind viele verletzt teilweise kämpfen
sie jetzt noch um ihr leben jetzt gerade
in diesen momenten große betroffenheit
große trauer jetzt an diesem tag nach
diesem verbrechen auch beim
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat getwittert
als sein mitgefühl zum ausdruck gebracht
die grausame amoktat an der
tauentzienstraße macht mich tief
betroffen schreibt er die reise einer
hessischen schulklasse nach berlin endet
im albtraum wir denken an die
angehörigen der toten und an die
verletzten darunter viele kinder ihnen
allen wünsche ich eine schnelle genesung
das teilt bundeskanzler olaf scholz mit
wir machen eine ganz kurze pause hierbei
bild live ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei rainer wendt